WILL TUNE IN FOR THAT.
SEAN HANNITY AWAITS FROM NEW
YORK.
>> SEAN: WELCOME TO HANNITY, A
LOT OF COVERS TONIGHT.
BIDEN’S BASEMENT BUNKER, PULLS A
RAPIDLY CHANGING BEFORE OUR
EYES, THE MEDIA MOB IS NOW MORE
NERVOUS THAN EVER.
FORMER FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA
STOKING DIVISION AS SHE MAKES
CLAIMS OF RACISM FOR WHEN SHE
WAS FIRST LADY.
THE FAR LEFT AS MERE CAMPAIGN IN
FULL GEAR TONIGHT.
WE ARE JUST 64 DAYS AWAY FROM
YOU BEING THE ULTIMATE JURY, AND
THAT IS ELECTION DAY
NOVEMBER 3rd.
THIS SEASON OF LYING IN SMEARS
IS WELL UNDERWAY PER USUAL,
DEMOCRATS AND COMPLACENT
PARTNERS IN THE MOB IN THE MEDIA
THEY SPEAK WITH ONE VOICE.
FIRST REMEMBER THEY TOLD THEIR
FOLLOWERS TO TAKE TO THE STREETS
AND RESIST RATE IN ONE VOICE
THEY CALLED FOR LET’S SEE
HARASSMENT, AND NEVER CONDEMN
THE VIOLENCE, IT WAS A LITTLE
SCARY.
THE NEXT ONE, AMERICAN CITY
START BURNING BEFORE OUR VERY
EYES, THEY IGNORE IT AS IT’S A
MYTH, AND THEN THEY MOB THEY
ECHO THAT LIE AND PRETEND IT’S
NOT HAPPENING.
THEY COVER IT UP IN OTHER WORDS.
AND NOW, IN ONE VOICE, WELL,
OKAY, WE CAN’T DENY IT ANY
LONGER, SO LET’S GO TO THE SAME
OLD SAME OLD AND BLAME PRESIDENT
TRUMP FOR THE WEEKS AND WEEKS
AND WEEKS ALMOST 100 DAYS OF
DESTRUCTION CARRIED OUT BY
LEFT-WING AND ARCHIVISTS.
TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO PEEL
BACK THE LAYERS OF THIS
POLITICAL DECEPTION.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL HANNITY
INVESTIGATION INTO WHAT IS THE
MOST RADICAL EXTREME AGENDA AND
PLATFORM FROM ANY MAJOR
POLITICAL PARTY IN MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY, AND OF COURSE
THEIR DUPLICITOUS PARTNERS THAT
MEDIA MOB WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
JOE BIDEN, 2016, WHEN HE WAS
SLIGHTLY LESS WEAK IN FRAIL, HE
TOLD THE CROWD OF SUPPORTERS HE
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE DONALD TRUMP
BEHIND THE GYM AND BEAT HIM UP
FOLLOWING WEEKS AND MONTHS AND
YEARS OF CHORUS OF DEMOCRATS AND
MOB MEMBERS AND THE MEDIA, THEY
VILIFIED THE PRESIDENT EVERY
SECOND, MINUTE, AND HOUR OF
EVERY DAY.
THEY VIOLENT THEY AGAINST
HARASSMENT FOR PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT.
HILLARY IS TERRIBLE RUNNING MATE
CALLING FOR THE SUPPORTERS TO
FIGHT IN THE STREETS.
OBAMA’S ATTORNEY GENERAL
PRAISING ANTI- TRUMP TRUMP
RIOTERS WHO MARCHED AND BLED AND
DIED.
SENATOR CORY BOOKER TELLING
ACTIVIST TO GET UP IN THE FACE
OF THEIR POLITICAL ENEMIES.
SO DO DID CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE
WATERS TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT
WELCOME ANYWHERE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY’RE CALLING FOR UNREST IN
THE STREETS.
KAMALA HARASSING RIOTS AREN’T
GOING TO STOP AND SHOULDN’T
STOP.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO, SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE NANCY PELOSI CALLING
REPUBLICANS ENEMIES OF THE
STATE.
THE WASHINGTON POST TELLING
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY SHOULD BE
BURNED TO THE GROUND WE SHOULD
LEVEL THEM.
THIS KIND OF RHETORIC IS NOTHING
NEW.
REMEMBER, OBAMA HIMSELF
ENCOURAGED HIS SUPPORTERS TO GET
IN THE FACES OF THEIR NEIGHBORS,
AND HE WOULD BY THE WAY SEND A
GUY NAMED MISTER BURGESS TO TEAR
ME UP, SEAN HANNITY.
SADLY IT’S JUST A SMALL PART OF
THE NEVER ENDING NONSTOP
PSYCHOTIC HYSTERIA AMONG
DEMOCRATS AND OF COURSE THEIR
ALLIES IN THE MEDIA MOB.
TAKE A LOOK.
GIG YOU’D BE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET IN A RESTAURANT, OR A
GASOLINE STATION, YOU GET OUT
AND YOU SAY TO THE CROWD.
YOU TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT
WELCOME PAIRED.
>> THEY ASK YOU IF I WOULD LIKE
TO DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN I SAID
NO, IF WE WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL I
WOULD TIKI HIM BEHIND THE GYM
AND BEAT THE OUT OF THEM.
>> THEY’RE NOT GOING TO DROP
BEFORE ELECTION DAY IN THE NOT
GOING TO STOP AFTER ELECTION
DAY.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO LET UP AND
THEY SHOULD NOT.
>> THEY SHOULDN’T LET UP, OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN
SLANDERED, SMEARED, LIBELED, USE
MERGE, DEHUMANIZED COMPARED TO
AND FASCIST, CALLED PRETTY MUCH
EVERY NAME IN THE BOOK.
ISN’T REALLY A COINCIDENCE THAT
THE FAR LEFT RADICAL BAYS AT
THAT DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE
RIOTING IN NEARLY EVERY CITY.
NOT ONLY DID HIGH-PROFILE
DEMOCRATS AND JOURNALISTS
ENCOURAGES KIND OF VIOLENCE
DAILY, THEY DESTRUCTIVE RIOTS TO
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL PAIRED
THEY IGNORED OR VILE THEY
MINIMIZED IT.
LIBERAL MAYORS AND BLOCK THIS
POLICE FROM BLOCKING CROWDS OF
AGITATORS.
THEY SLASHED POLICE BUDGETS BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN APPLAUDING THIS SAYING
THAT HE WOULD ABSOLUTELY
REDIRECT POLICE FRIENDING
BECAUSE POLICE HAVE BECOME THE
ENEMY.
HIS RADICAL RUNNING MATE KAMALA
HARRIS PRAISING LOS ANGELES FOR
SLASHING ITS POLICE BUDGET BY
$150 MILLION.
THEY DISBAND THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT, AND MEANWHILE,
POLICE ARE LITERALLY UNDER FIRE
AND ATTACKED DAILY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO FAR THIS YEAR, 30 POLICE
OFFICERS HAVE BEEN SHOT AND
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
THOUSANDS MORE HAVE BEEN
SERIOUSLY WOUNDED, ASSAULTED,
STABBED WITH KNIVES, HIT WITH
ROCKS AND FROZEN WATER, CANES,
BATS, HOCKEY STICKS, MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
MEMBERS OF BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN
DONATED TO A FUND DEDICATED TO
BAILING THESE VIOLENT OFFENDERS
OUT OF JAIL, PITCHED BY THE WAY
IF HE BECOMES PRESIDENT THERE
WILL BE NO BAIL JUST LIKE THEY
HAVE NO BILL IN NEW YORK.
IN OREGON FAR LEFT GOVERNOR BAND
POLICE FROM ACTUALLY USING TEAR
GAS.
THE SAME THING IN SEATTLE.
WE SAW THE SEATTLE MAYOR MAKE
THAT DECISION.
TED WHEELER PREVENTED POLICE
FROM DISPERSING RIOTERS AND
ARRESTED ARSONIST.
UNDER HIS WATCH A FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE WAS ATTACKED, LIT ON
FIRE FOR WEEKS ON AND UNTIL THE
PRESIDENT WAS SENT PEOPLE IN,
TROOPS INTO PROTECT THOSE
FEDERAL BUILDINGS.
OVER THE WEEKEND IN PORTLAND,
ONE TRUMP SUPPORTER WAS SHOT BY
A SELF PROCLAIMED MEMBER OF
ANTIFA.
THAT CITY HAS HAD VIOLENT
RIOTS.
SEATTLE WAS HELD HOSTAGE BY A
GROUP OF FAR LEFT RIOTERS, CITY
OFFICIALS FORCED THE POLICE TO
TOTALLY ABANDON THEIR LOCAL
PRECINCT.
THEIR GENIUS MAYOR, SHE WAS
TELLING US IT WAS A SUMMER OF
LOVE ZONE, THAT WAS UNTIL TO
YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN TEENS
WERE MURDERED IN THE SO-CALLED
AUTONOMOUS CHOP ZONE.
THE MEDIA MOB TRIED THEIR BEST
TO COVER UP ALL OF THIS THIS
MASSIVE WAVE OF VIOLENCE.
WHILE THEY ARE BEING CORRECTED
ON LIVE TV.
MINNEAPOLIS WAS BURNING, MS NBC
SAID IT WAS A MOSTLY PEACEFUL
PROCESS AND LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS.
YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS UP.
FAKE NEWS CNN REFERRING TO THE
CARNAGE IN KENOSHA, WISCONSIN.
LOOK AT WHAT THE BOTTOM THIRD
SAYS, FIERY, BUT MOSTLY
PEACEFUL.
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT THAT
PICTURE.
OF COURSE THEY’RE NOT THE ONLY
ONES RUNNING COVER FOR AN ANGRY
FAR LEFT MOB TAKE A LOOK FOR
YOURSELF.
>> THEY GOT INVOLVED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
>> VIOLENCE ACROSS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
IT’S HAPPENING IN PORTLAND RIGHT
NOW.
>> THAT’S A MYTH BEDS BEING
SPREAD ONLY IN WASHINGTON, DC.
>> IT’S A MYTH.
DON’T BELIEVE WHAT YOUR EYES
TELL YOU.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THIS NASTY HABIT
OF IGNORING VIOLENCE WHEN IT
HURTS THEM.
POLITICALLY.
FOR EXAMPLE IN OBAMA’S HOMETOWN
OF CHICAGO, NEITHER BARACK OR
JOE LIFTED A FINGER IN EIGHT
YEARS TO FIX THE WEEKLY
OUT-OF-CONTROL VIOLENT CRIME
THEY ARE.
THAT’S OBAMA’S HOME CITY.
MEANWHILE FOR YEARS ON THIS
PROGRAM, WE TRIED HARD TO SHINE
A LIGHT ON THAT VERY SERIOUS
CRISIS.
WE SCROLLED THE NAMES OF
SHOOTING VICTIMS ON THE SCREEN.
WE PLEADED WITH BOTH JOE AND
BARACK AND THERE IT MINISTRATION
TO GET TO WORK.
LET’S TAKE A TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE, SHOULD WE?
>> 3,470, WE DON’T HEAR A PEEP
OUT OF OBAMA.
HE SPOKEN OUT IN EIGHT YEARS
NINE TIMES, BUT IF IT’S A
HIGH-PROFILE CASE, HE IS FRONT
AND CENTER.
HE ADVANCES THE NARRATIVE, NO
DUE PROCESS, NO ASSUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
>> I KNOW I’VE AGED, BUT THE
POINT STAYS THE SAME.
50 YEARS IN THE WASHINGTON
SWAMP, ASK YOURSELF WHAT HAS JOE
BIDEN EVER DONE TO IMPROVE
AMERICAN CITIES?
WHAT DOES HE EVER DO?
WHY DID HE FEEL THE PEOPLE OF
CHICAGO, THE THOUSAND SHOT IN
THE THOUSANDS DEAD?
WHY DIDN’T HE FIX BALTIMORE
AFTER WHAT HAPPENED, THE
UPRISING IN THE FREDDIE GRAY
CASE?
WHAT DID HE DO IN FERGUSON,
MISSOURI AFTER WHAT HAPPENED
WITH MICHAEL BROWN AND OFFICER
DARREN WILSON, WHO BY THE WAY
THE DOJ OF OBAMA SAID WAS A
JUSTIFIED SHOOTING IN THE END.
SO WHAT DID JOE DO TO MAKE
AMERICA A BETTER AND SAFER PLACE
FOR ALL AMERICANS AND RESTORE
LAW AND ORDER?
WHAT POLICE REFORM, WHAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM?
THAT’S RIGHT, PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID ALL THOSE
THINGS FOR THE UP ANSWER FOR JOE
IS HE DID NOTHING EXCEPT SO
DIVISION BY CONSTANTLY RUSHING
TO JUDGMENT AND NOW BIDEN
DEMOCRATS, THE MOB, AND THE
MEDIA ARE BEING FORCED TO
ADDRESS THE VIOLENCE IN AMERICAN
CITIES.
THEY CAN NO LONGER DENY REALITY
AFTER 100 NIGHTS, BUT NOT
BECAUSE OF THE CARNAGE OR THE
ASSAULT OR THE THREATS, OR THE
ARSON, OR THE MURDERS, THEY
DON’T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT ANY OF
THAT.
FOR THEM, IT’S ALL ABOUT THE
POLLS, AND IT’S ALL ABOUT
ELECTION.
LISTEN TO DON LEMON ON FAKE
NEWS, CNN.
>> THE RIOTING HAS TO STOP.
CHRIS, AS YOU KNOW AND I KNOW,
IT SHOWING UP IN THE BOWLING.
IT SHOWING UP IN FOCUS GROUPS.
IT IS THE ONLY THING, IT IS THE
ONLY THING RIGHT NOW THAT IS
STICKING.
>> IT STICKING, WE BETTER DEAL
WITH THIS BECAUSE WE’VE BEEN
DENYING IT, BUT WE WILL DEAL
WITH IT NOW FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES ONLY.
SO THEY WILL DEAL WITH IT FOR 64
DAYS AND GO BACK TO IGNORING IT?
AFTER MONTHS OF COVERING UP THE
CHAOS IN AMERICA’S CITIES, THEY
NOW SUDDENLY AT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THIS KIND OF
VIOLENCE IS NOT GOOD HERE IS THE
CATCH, THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE YET AGAIN SPEAKING
WITH ONE VOICE PER EIGHT IF WE
HAVE TO ADMIT IT, LET’S JUST
BLAME DONALD TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT
OF FANNING THE FLAMES OF
VIOLENCE.
VANITY FAIR SAYING THE SAME
THING.
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL DAYS THE
SAME LANGUAGE WAS ECHOED OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY ARE ONE MIND, THEY ARE THE
PROPAGANDA MEDIA WING AND THE
DEMOCRATIC WROTE RADICAL
SOCIALIST PARTY.
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THE
PRESIDENT APPEARING TO INFLAME
TENSIONS INSTEAD OF WHAT WE
NORMALLY SEE FROM PRESIDENTS
WHICH IS TRYING TO CALM THEM
DOWN?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS WILLFULLY
FANNING THE FLAMES OF THIS
VIOLENCE.
>> EASILY CONDEMNED THE VIOLENCE
AND CALLED FOR PEACEFUL
PRESENTATIONS.
TRUMP IS NOT THAT THAT.
IT IS THE TRUMP SUPPORTERS OUT
HERE CAUSING MAYHEM.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO FANS
THE FLAMES RATHER THAN FIGHTING
THE FLAMES SPREAD FLAME SPREAD.
>> THE PRESIDENT DOES NOT HAVE A
PLAN, HE HAS FANNED THE FLAMES.
>> SEAN: HE IS THE EXACT SAME
WORDS, KEEP IN MIND IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO OFFERED
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE TWO EVERY
EVERYONE OF THESE CITIES AND
STATES OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN TO RESTORE LAW AND ORDER
AND SAFETY AND SECURITY AND
CONTROL AND STOP THE VIOLENT.
THEY WOULD RATHER TAKE THEIR
CHEAP POLITICAL SHOTS AT DONALD
TRUMP AND THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TURNED DOWN BY AMERICA’S DUMB
LIBERAL MAYORS AND GOVERNORS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
APPARENTLY THEY WOULD RATHER
WATCH THEIR CITIES BURN AND
INNOCENT PEOPLE GET HURT AND USE
IT POLITICALLY TO BLAME DONALD
TRUMP FOR THEM NOT DOING THEIR
JOB.
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING ABOUT
THE CRISIS, THIS IS THEIR NUMBER
ONE ACTUAL RESPONSIBILITY.
LATER AFTER THIS SHOW, LAURA
INGRAHAM INTERVIEWED THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THIS TOPIC.
HERE IS A PREVIEW OF WHAT HE HAS
TO SAY.
>> BIDEN SAID AGAIN TODAY IN
PITTSBURGH THAT ESSENTIALLY, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO BE SAFE AND IN
DONALD TRUMP’S AMERICA.
>> SO IF IT WEREN’T DONALD TRUMP
AMERICAS, TO USE THE EXPRESSION
IS AN PRESIDENT, THEN YOU WOULD
HAVE RIOTS LIKE YOU’VE NEVER
SEEN.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE LOST CONTROL
OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
DON’T FORGET, BIDEN WASN’T GOING
TO COME OUT OF HIS BASEMENT
UNTIL THE ELECTION.
NOW HE HAD TO BECAUSE THE POLLS
ARE SO GOOD FOR ME.
ARE DIFFERENT.
COULD GIVE THE PRESIDENT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT, JOE BIDEN IS JUST
LYING TO YOU IN THE ELECTION
YEAR CONVERSION RADICAL
DEMOCRATS ARE LYING TO YOU, THE
MOB AS USUAL THEY ARE LYING TO
YOU IN AS WE ALL WILL KNOW THESE
ARE THE SAME GROUPS OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN LYING IN UNISON
FOR YEARS FOR THE ONES THAT LIED
TO THE ENTIRE COUNTRY ABOUT
NONEXISTENT TRUMP AND RUSSIA
COLLUSION WALL IGNORING THE
CLEAR COLLUSION AND THAT IS
HILLARY CLINTON’S LOT BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THEY LIED ABOUT QUID PRO QUO,
BUT THEY HAVE JOE BIDEN ON TAPE
YOU NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS UNTIL YOU BY THE
PROSECUTOR INVESTIGATING MY SON
BEING PAID MILLIONS.
OUT, HE DID ALL OF THAT.
NOW A DIFFERENT TOPIC, SAME
TACTIC.
THEY HAVE BEEN STOKING THE
FLAMES OF VIOLENCE AMONG THE
RADICAL MEMBERS FEARFUL TO
CORRECT THEM AND STOP THEM AND
SPEAK OUT AGAINST THEM AS PER
USUAL, LET’S BLAME DONALD TRUMP
FOR THAT TOO.
IF YOU’RE FEELING SAD, OF COURSE
IT’S DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
DONALD TRUMP CURED CANCER HOW
MANY TIMES WHAT I SAY THEY WOULD
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM FOR THAT TO?
MAKE NO MISTAKE, WHAT WE ARE ALL
SEEING IN SEATTLE, PORTLAND,
KENOSHA, WISCONSIN,, NEW YORK
CITY, ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, THIS
IS WHAT I CALL A PREVIEW OF
COMING ATTRACTIONS IF JOE BIDEN
IS ELECTED PRESIDENT IN 64 DAYS.
THE CHOICE IS YOURS, YOU’RE THE
ULTIMATE JURY.
WILL AMERICA CAVED TO THE
RADICALISM OR WILL YOU VOTE TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY AND SECURITY
OF YOUR TOWN AND CITY?
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME